des mains en or ils sont ébéniste
couvreurs ou maîtres verriers et depuis
des décennies leur savoir-faire a fait
d'eux des artisans de renom des artisans
en service du patrimoine qu'ils
travaillent seuls ou en équipes ils sont
tous animés par la même passion leur
métier au beau milieu de la côte
chalonnaise antonin bouchard a installé
son atelier il ya plus de 30 ans dans le
domaine viticole familial ébéniste
depuis quatre décennies
il est spécialisé dans le mobilier du
12e au xviie siècle alors antonin vous
travaillez voilà sur la restauration
d'un coffre anglo normand et début du
16e qui enchaîne manier parce qu'en fait
c'est un chêne qui est tranché sur
quartier et pour ça il faut du bois
anciens justement à grain fin pour
pouvoir permettre d'avoir une belle
restauration des meubles comme ça ils
ont été restaurées au 19e ou départ
c'était un coffre ils ont fait un
placard parce que c'est pas pratique
donc j'en ai deux portes et le but c'est
de le remettre dans l'esprit où ils
étaient 500 heures de travail seront
nécessaires pour la restauration de ce
qu'offre une pièce d'exception
démonstration d'un savoir-faire
principale clientèle d'antonin les
particuliers un marché difficile la
restauration demande en effet beaucoup
de temps et de main d'oeuvre il à
l'addition peut vite grimper manager
quelques meubles surfer vue là par
exemple j'ai fait enlever en amour
1900 euros ttc à peu près pour un petit
meuble qui dans une salle des ventes
pourrait peut-être 300 euros mais bon
les clients y tiennent donc
j'attends leur accord avant d'attaquer
des travaux restauration mais aussi
création
antonin travaille actuellement sur des
fenêtres destinées aux hospices de
beaune
s'il est sollicité régulièrement pour la
sauvegarde du patrimoine bâti là
quelques regrets concernant le mobilier
c'est un peu le parent contre mon
problème c'est que on laisse dans l'état
faut pas y toucher
on montre pas les partis qui ont été
refaites et un tableau on va passer du
temps de sûr on va faire des études
meubles en fait rien à 130 km de là en
côte d'or
un chantier d'envergure l'église de
poncey sur lignon se refait une beauté
au coeur des attentions la toiture en
lave de pierre une singularité
architecturale pour la bourgogne
depuis l'été 2010 est antonio recondo
couvreur lavier travaillent sur ce
chantier avec son fils thomas et arnold
son ouvrier à taille de la pierre calage
les gestes son furet d'une apparente
simplicité
pourtant le travail de la lawe requiert
une grande dextérité
attention la pierre de lave n'a ici rien
de volcaniques
elle doit son nom à l'expression pierres
levées c'est à dire extraites en surface
cela c'est que c'est que de la
prestation c'est que là un marteau puis
on fait tout de a à z
on fait des les rives où les amitiés les
nous enfin que peuple à tulle il faut il
faut que chaque accessoire que là on se
transforme chaque paire ans je vous dis
de a à z on peut faire le métier et il
vous annonce quoi c'est tout citect
maire de la commune agents de la drac
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la visite
du chantier et antonio signale un
problème de taille la carrière n'a plus
de stock pour trouver des grands formats
en 3 5 c'est difficile au même endroit
mais on sait que vous êtes exigeante
ajouté mais quand tu peux rien vous
refusez initiée par madame le maire ce
chantier supervisé par frédéric didier
architecte en chef des monuments
historiques
il est notamment en charge de versailles
move ou pour lui entre cette église et
le château du roi soleil
la relation est évidente le lien c'est
l'excellence et la beauté de toute façon
il n'ya pas de petit patrimoine
il ya du patrimoine et est ce que vous
avez là c'est vraiment l'expression de à
la fois d'un art d'une technique d'une
beauté d'une intelligence à travers les
siècles
huit cent mille euros c'est le montant
du lifting de cette église du xviiie
siècle
financé à 90% par l'état le département
ce type de chantier ne sauvegarde pas
uniquement le patrimoine
c'est un conservatoire des techniques ça
c'est très très important parce que
sinon la restauration du patrimoine ça
viendra comme le latin c'est une langue
morte
et le jour où c'est une langue morte on
peut plus le faire dire qu'est ce qu'on
fera on saura plus faire et ça c'est une
technique qui a failli se perdre
l'indien et transmission d'un savoir
faire c'est aussi la préoccupation
d'antonio après dix années de
collaboration son fils va reprendre le
flambeau
non sans appréhension et j'espère que
oui
au niveau des chantiers tout ça va durer
près ça coûte tellement cher à l'oeuvre
que la peau grande qui peut se procurer
un toit comme à particuliers par exemple
a vraiment beaucoup de subventions
chez les retours de la troisième
génération déjà en formation
jane cinq ans devra encore attendre
quelques années pour monter sur un toit
[Musique]
strasbourg
et sa cathédrale au style gothique
flamboyant après la restauration des
rosaces de la façade sud en côte d'or
les ateliers part au travail depuis
plusieurs semaines sur les vitraux de
l'horloge
ces deux saints chevaliers du 12e et 19e
siècles sont bientôt prêt à retrouver
l'alsace en pierres on va regarder
surtout les collages et les comblements
si elles ont été faits dans les courses
qu'on avait prévu 7les cela doit être
inversée faudra qu'on regarde ça parce
que regarde le tiffany le la casse était
là est la seule que la pièce et
réinverser pierre-alain parrot et tout
comme son père avant lui
maître verrier son atelier basé à 20 km
de dijon est l'un des quatre plus grands
de france spécialisée dans la
restauration il emploie 14 salariés dont
sa fille très adhérente
m faccini coup action mécanique des
remèdes parmi d'autres ici les blouses
blanches sont au chevet des oeuvres
d'art
l'objectif atténuer les effets du temps
tout en préservant l ouvrage
aujourd'hui c'est la conservation
maximale on ne regarde l'histoire du
vitra ici un bouche trou si cette pièce
là par exemple est dû et du 16e siècle
un côté d'une pièce du 12e et on va la
laisser évidemment on sait ça fait
partie de l'histoire du vitrail danse et
la conservation maximale après le
nettoyage place au collage au fil du
temps des plombs ont été parfois
ajoutées pour réparer des verres cassés
aujourd'hui une résine permet de
supprimer les plombs superflu c'est la
spécialité d'arnaud mais aussi sa plus
grande fierté que j'adore en fait c'est
redonner une lecture du vitrail
avec les restaurations de passer il ya
souvent beaucoup de plomb qui cas les
pièces ont été cassés on ne comprend
plus rien il ya plus de lecture est là
quand ça passe à la phase collage on
redonne une lecture c'est ce que je
préfère
arnaud comme la plupart des salariés a
été formé ici
frédéric lui est passé par lyon et
valence il s'occupe de la remise en
plomb avec plus de vingt ans de métier
le vitrail et toujours pour lui ni
passion de la ferronnerie de la
serrurerie à la taille de pierre il ya
du montage et de la coupe c'est quelque
chose de commandeur c'est très complets
tout en étant assez compliqué c'est pour
ça qu'on met beaucoup de temps à être
formés puisqu'on touche à beaucoup de
choses qui à chaque vitrail chaque
église chaque réalisation à apporte une
connaissance encore qu'on a à cosnac et
au fur et à mesure donc nous on
considère que fo vont de 10 à 12 ans
pratique vraiment dans un atelier comme
ici pourra pour maîtriser prendre une
certaine autonomie et une autonomie un
jeu made in maîtrise une autonomie
vraiment pour confier à un travail
complet transmettre son savoir faire et
par là même sa passion c'est l'une des
préoccupations de ses artisans
si les prétendants ne ment pas la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat des particuliers et
le recul des dotations de l'état ont
fragilisé le secteur
[Musique]
et